want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only bob proctor
enjoy
i want you to think of this for a moment
let's suppose there was a virus going
around and this virus caused people to
really stunt their growth ruin their
income and cause them to mix with people
who are on the wrong track and it was a
virus and there didn't seem to be any
prescription to solve the problem we
would be in panic state we would be
looking everywhere for some kind of a
prescription to fix and kill this virus
well do you know that's what a paradigm
is a paradigm is a program that is
lodged in your subconscious mind in your
innate mind it has been placed there
genetically from the moment of
conception all mom's dna and all dad's
dna is your dna and then there's an
attractive force set up and when you are
born then your environment becomes part
of the paradigm why do you think so many
people are struggling why do you think
only three or four percent live a truly
full wealthy meaningful life is because
everybody is caught up in the paradigm
when i started to study this when i
started to understand it it just about
blew my mind and then when i found out i
could change it i could take a pen and
write my own paradigm and live the way i
really wanted to live
i almost found it hard to believe you
know the law of success is a pretty
interesting concept
there's been books written on it stories
told on it
lives have been
spent looking for it
let's understand that
everything operates by law
the whole universe operates by law
the best definition of success i have
ever heard
was one that earl nightingale originated
way back 1959 he said success is the
progressive realization
of a worthy ideal
well let's break that down for a moment
success is the progressive
continually moving progressive
realization constant awareness
of a worthy ideal
an ideal is an idea that you have fallen
in love with an ideal is an idea that
you're intellectually emotionally and
physically involved with
an ideal is an idea that you fall in
love with success is the progressive
realization of the worthy ideal so you
don't ask are you worthy of the idea
are you worthy of the good
is it worthy of you
now now you're getting in to law of
success
is it worthy of you you see what you're
going to do is trade your life
you're trading your life for whatever it
is you're going after
so you want to make up your mind
whatever your goal happens to be
whatever you are pursuing make certain
it's worthy of you because you're
trading your life for it
the law of success
calls for you
to continually moving toward a
predetermined objective in life
and bringing your life in harmony with
the laws that cover the entire universe
think of this for a moment
do you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time
figure it out
you get all there is
a hobo sleeping under a bridge or on a
park bench
that has no material possessions
nan
does nothing of any
constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time as the most
productive industrialist in the world
we all get exactly the same amount of
time so it's what we do with the time
that makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun has time management
programs
in fact i made one one time spent a lot
of money on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money
do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
and it was downtown chicago
and i was going with him on a speaking
engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever el nino said you want to meet
me i was there and i always had some
well-prepared questions and i remember
asking him i said uh how did you learn
how to master time management you know
we're having breakfast i can still hear
his fork hit the plate he's what the
hell you're talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
he's i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket
and he said every night before i go to
bed i write down six most important
things i have to do tomorrow these are
goal achieving activities and when i
wake up that's what i start working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six now if i have
three that i didn't get done today that
doesn't mean i have nine for tomorrow
like six plus these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up you give all your
conscious attention to do those things
see you cannot manage time
but you can manage activity
you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference make certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
i uh met a man here in toronto he was
one that originally got me involved in
studying this ray stanford
and he told me if i didn't like the
results i was getting in my life that i
was going to have to change me because
there were my results
and he said if you're going to change
you you're going to have to find out
something about yourself
and that seemed to make
sense i don't think it was an
earth-shattering idea it wouldn't give
anybody a brain hernia but it made a
hell of a lot of sense to me so i
started to study myself i found most
people don't know who they are
they really don't
what do you mean i mean i know my name i
know my age i know where yeah that's not
what else is there you know that that
size if you ask the average person who
they are they'll give you their name
they'll say i'm bob proctor but i'm not
bob and proctor are two words my parents
give them to me they're called names but
it's not me it's my name
then somebody will say well this is me
but this isn't me either it's my body
like you never phone down here to the to
the studio and say body won't be in
today it's sick okay you know we don't
say am hand ram leg it's my hand my leg
my body my name
who am i
well that's an interesting question and
i believe if a person will start to
study that
and look for the answer they'll find it
see i think we live simultaneously on
three planes of understanding we're
spiritual creatures we have an intellect
and we live in physical bodies
okay but because we lack awareness or
understanding of who we are we're
totally locked into a physical world and
we let things outside of us control us
ninety-five percent of the population
are reacting to life they're not really
living at all i don't think you
determine what your purpose is i think
you discover what your purpose is
there's a difference determining
indicates deciding
um
[Music]
and i don't think you decide i think if
you go about it the right way you
discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting
all day they're great artists
i think michelangelo was obviously a
great artist great sculptor
i mean
that was his purpose
in his life
well
i believe my purpose is doing what i'm
doing
your purpose is why you get out of bed
in the morning do you know why you get
up well most people say well it's to go
to work well that'd be a good reason to
stay in bed you know you say well
everybody's doing it that'd be another
reason to stay in bed if you're ever
doing what everybody's doing you're
probably going in the wrong direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down
and maybe
take a pen
and a pad
and then ask yourself what do i really
love doing now you may have to spend a
while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning
and
go sit under a tree somewhere if you're
in a nice climate
or pick a favorite chair someplace where
you're not going to be disturbed
and totally relax
and say
if i could spend my life doing something
what do i really love doing
now since you don't ask yourself that
question every day it might take a while
for this answer to come to the surface
but it comes
to your consciousness
and it may take a while you may have to
do this every morning for
three months
but it would be
well invested the time
how many times have you had somebody say
to you have you got a minute but
you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that
i read a poem one time i said i have
only just a minute
only 60 seconds in it
it was forced upon me i can't refuse it
i didn't seek it and i didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it i must
suffer if i lose it give a count if i
abuse it it's only a tiny little minute
but eternity is in it
well anyway i thought i'm going to put
this on a video and i'm just going to
share with everybody just this one
little part of the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sand timer
and let this i want you to think about
your life the sand in the top of the
glass represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past
now do you know we know what's in the
past and yet we can't do anything about
it do you know what the trick is you
don't know how much sands in the top of
the glass you may think you have a lot
you might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother and i don't know when i
was little gaffer she was probably 60
but
as long as i could remember grandma
would say and i'll soon be glad dear
i'll soon be gone well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of god but
we thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30 some years
i'll soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time i had a buddy of
mine bob yates he was just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left he would have
said at least a half a century he didn't
have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future
we don't know the past it's gone now the
only thing you can deal with is what's
right here right now and if you look the
sand is always moving
now think of this
you see i was working on that and then i
was working on a graph i've got here on
my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute
do you know if you're earning 50 000 a
year in minutes 42 cents
a half hour is 12.50
if we take that ahead of it if you're
earning 80 000 a year a minute 67 cents
half hour's 20 dollars
if you're earning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute
it cost you a dollar 25 a minute
a half
37.50 so if you see if somebody said you
and
hour's
want to stop for a cup of coffee
well
if you're earning a quarter of a million
dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hour is 62.50
and then of course you've got the coffee
to pay for on top of that
so you see
the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now and i have found the people that
win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen
every minute he said that success was
the progressive realization of a worthy
ideal anyone that has a goal and they're
moving towards it they're successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't i wouldn't say
mother teresa has a lot of money okay
but she's a pretty successful lady
so it's um
okay so that barrier to these well
there's a couple of them okay i think
there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time we're infants
all we can do is act and talk like the
people around us that's why we learn the
language we learned
if there was 10 languages spoken in our
home we'd learn 10 languages without any
trouble there's usually one and that's
the only one we ever learn and we grow
older and we think well i couldn't learn
another language we could learn 100 if
we wanted to you can do anything but i
think we're conditioned we have a
real strong conditioning usually with
not some very good ideas
and then that that's the
the barrier that's inside is the one
that's outside of us says our
environment we have a tendency to act
like everybody around us
and if you think about this it doesn't
make a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95 percent of the people live
their entire life and never live the way
they want to live
you know that 95 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
north america okay the richest continent
in the history of the world
they'll work productively let's say for
40 of their 65 years okay and they'll
end up with hardly any money
well there's got to be something wrong
so there's no five percent of the people
end up financially comfortable or
independent
are you trying to depress this bob
because that's uh no actually i think
it's i think it's quite an exciting idea
because
you see the idea behind it is that
anybody can win
anyone at all but if we start studying
these statistics i think we'll arrive at
the conclusion geez i better start
thinking for myself rather than follow
everybody
most people they get a job they look
around they see how everybody else is
doing their work and they start doing it
the same way
they should stop and think i wonder if
any of these people know what they're
doing
is there a better way to do it but don't
we have a need to fit in i mean we don't
want it we don't want to stand out we
don't want to get fired we don't make
waves
exactly exactly just fall into line you
know take a number be like everybody
around
now that'd be great in the animal
kingdom
but human beings aren't supposed to live
that way i think we should make a few
waves
we should maybe stand out be different
not not for the sake of being different
okay but because we are different
we all think different thoughts
and i believe we should start to think
and build images in our mind of what
we'd like to do and then set out and do
it okay emerson did that edison did that
marconi did that and samuel morse did
that
buck minister fuller did that we could
go on and on and on okay they were
different they stood out they made a few
waves
select a person who is already doing
something that you'd like to do get to
know that person
go to the experts for advice don't ask
the person next door your mother father
brother the guy that works beside you
because they don't necessarily know
there's no point in asking a person to
earn a lot of money if they're only
earning ten thousand a year they don't
know they knew they'd probably be
earning a lot
it's like don't go to a sick doctor if
you want to get healthy okay so you find
someone that you can go to for advice
get a real good book and lock into that
book and start to study it like
i've had this one looks like a bible you
know
but this is napoleon hill's book think
and grow rich i've been reading this
thing now for 23 years
i'll probably read it for another 23
years
i get another good book that i brought
over here today it's called the power of
your subconscious mind
i'm not getting the commission for
selling this the author's
dead now he's been gone for a couple of
years but dr joseph murphy wrote this
book the power of your subconscious mind
and that's probably one of the best
books that you're ever going to find
because you're going to learn something
about your mind when you read this book
okay now i read a lot of books i've got
probably a thousand bucks sitting in my
den at home in my library but the one
that i care i carry it everywhere i go
and i read it all the time this thing
can grow rich i never stop reading it
where's the value for you to re-read
that and read it i mean you must you
must know it well enough that uh i think
i could probably recite it verbatim but
the secret is i once read in the book
where it said when you read a good book
through
the second time
you don't see something in it that you
didn't see before you see something in
yourself that wasn't there before you
see when i read this i created a greater
awareness do you know that the law of
attraction is always working it's like
the law of gravity if i let this go it's
going to go down it's never going to go
back up it's going to go down that is
the law of gravity anything heavier than
earth is attracted towards the center of
the world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that'll keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind now the
subconscious mind has been programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was go just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white type thon the paradigm
will kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable that's stepping out of the
box that's doing things different and we
don't like to do things different
because it causes a lot of discomfort
but understand this the paradigm and the
thinking control the vibration you're in
and the vibration is going to dictate
what you attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said
and you know something my income went
from four thousand to 175 000 in a year
and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
and another lesson i'm going to show you
how to change the paradigm when you
change the paradigm the change in
results is automatic you know why you
start to attract something new something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information
and eliminate the negative
i'm going to show you how to do that
law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good we're in a negative vibration
you want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for
but understand this
you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the paradigm and get you on that
frequency spot proctor and thank you see
people don't resist change people resist
being changed
yes
we've got to change ourself we've got to
build a new image a picture in our mind
we've got to see ourself the way we want
to be and then we have to live with it
that's you go to the gym workout that's
what you do
you build a picture how you want to see
this arm this arm and you build that
picture and then you build the body well
you build the life in your mind take
your pen and write out how you want to
live and always start by writing i'm so
happy and grateful now that and the
second you write it you've got it
intellectually the moment you impress it
upon your emotional mind you've got it
emotionally and it's only a period of
time till it manifests on the physical
plane
spirit works from a higher to a lower
potential habits
good habits will give you results that
stick bad habits will destroy everything
i have some bad habits
that's right all my habits are not great
so if you've got some bad habits
don't feel bad so does your next door
neighbor so does your mentor your coach
so does your mother and father if
they're alive so does everyone and the
trick of life is to replace a bad habit
with a good habit
i used to hang around bars all the time
and one day i went in i picked up a
glass and i looked around and i thought
they're all bums in here
and then it dawned on me i'm always here
i learned something i put the glass down
i said i'm never coming back here again
and i'm never going to drink this and i
never did that was a long time ago but
you know what i did
i went from spending all my money in the
bar to race track and i started to bet
it all on horses so i went from making
somebody with a bar get wealthy and then
i started to feed the horses
and one day i woke up and i learned
something if you don't consciously and
deliberately replace a bad habit with a
good habit you will automatically create
another bad habit
now what is a habit a habit is an idea
that has been planted in the garden of
your subconscious mind
and then repetitively fed for a
sufficient period of time that you act
on it without giving any thought to it
i'll give you an example i want you to
right now mentally imagine you're
pulling on your underwear in the morning
what foot do you put in first
i put my right foot in if i tried to put
my left foot in my underwear first i'd
stagger and i'd fall over
you may say what's this got to do with
it it's got everything to do with it
why do i put my right foot you may put
your left certainly a lot of people do
well when i was just a little gaffer
didn't have a clue of how to put
underwear on my mother or my grandmother
or my father or somebody came along and
they had the underwear red put your foot
in here you rather [ __ ]
what did they do
they had the underwear prepared as if
they were going to put it on
and so pretty soon i was doing it like
they were doing it
they through repetition planted the idea
in my hand in my mind well now think of
this
you don't just form habits of how to get
dressed you form habits to do everything
that you do and some of them are not
that productive
any idea
that you keep dwelling on and impressing
upon your subconscious mind becomes
fixed in the subconscious mind a habit
is nothing but an idea that's fixed in
the subconscious mind that you act on
without giving any conscious thought
many years ago i went in to train the
prudential insurance company of america
their agents i ended up training all of
their agents
and i only got them to do two things
this is in the early 70s i got them to
form the habit of being in front of a
prospect before 9 00 a.m and ask
everybody they talked to to purchase a
hundred thousand dollars worth of
insurance i said you don't have to sell
them just give them the opportunity to
say no
you know the sales in that company went
up by hundreds of millions of dollars i
had a revive a retired vp tell me he
thought it was a billion
just changing two habits
what habit you want to change
i'm forever checking out habits i've got
i'm in the habit right now of changing
my diet
and you know something
i've been doing it for going on three
weeks it's getting easier but it's still
not that easy i still like to reach over
and eat some of that when nobody's
looking
doesn't work doesn't work i'm looking
what habit are you going to form and you
shouldn't try and form more than two at
once it'll become too big and too heavy
and you won't form any
make up your mind you're going to do it
every day every day every day
until
you don't have to think about it and
then you'll automatically do it i
guarantee you
this idea will change your life think
about it all day
because that is definitely an idea that
will give you results that will stick
i'm going to share some information with
you that
it could change the direction of your
life like night and day
and when i say that i want you to really
stop and take a look at your life
take an honest look at your life i i was
thinking just before i start to make
this
we have actually been conditioned to kid
with ourselves to lie to ourselves
to um
not really
take an honest look at the results we're
getting
i want you to take a real honest look at
your results
and
when you look at them ask yourself
am i living the way i really want to
live
you see most people aren't one of the
first questions i ask a person that
comes to work with me i want to know
what's the most they've ever earned in a
year now i really don't care what the
answer is but i want to know what the
answer is
because you see
um
if a person says the most i've ever
earned in a year is 50 000
i know where their mind is programmed
um if they tell me the most they've ever
earned is 250 000
i know where they're programmed
and then i want to find out what they
want
and i know then
what has to shift
because their mind is programmed and if
they're really going to live the way
they want to live they
they've got to change the program
and if they don't change the program
then nothing really happens talk about
people paying themselves they pay
everything under the sun but they don't
pay themselves
think of when you're on a plane
and
the oxygen mask may drop down
there's a problem with oxygen in the
plane
they will tell you if you have a child
with you put your own on first
because you can't look after the kids if
you haven't got your self looked after
well that's exactly the same with money
look after yourself first if you don't
pay yourself
you're soon going to
treat yourself and just not do very well
we are building a picture
in our mind here this is an idea
we could say it's a goal
then we impress that idea upon this part
of our personality
that's the idea in our mind
now what we've got to understand
is that
this part of our mind the subject of
mind
is actually universal intelligence
and this is really the way it is
when you press the id upon your
subconscious mind
you are
universally everywhere
now to help you think of that
where here's the
phone let's suppose you're in uh
i don't know
buenos aires
and
i'm right here
in north america
and i dial your number i've got you on
the phone
time and space means nothing because
i've got on to that frequency
and so you and i can communicate we're
connected
one person's in buenos aires or you
could say singapore you could say
shanghai and another one is in new york
or in toronto but they're connected why
the time and space means nothing
because you're dealing with energy
and you're dealing with laws
now when you impress this idea upon the
subconscious mind
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
and everything
anywhere in the universe
that's in harmony
that is a frequency understand that
that idea is a frequency
it's operating on a frequency
and so everything that's in harmony with
it
begins to move toward it
because then harmonious vibration and
you attract it
now
throw a slide up scott
look here for a moment
soaring
kikigaard
wrote something really
great on intuition
he said
listen you gotta listen you listen with
your emotions
we can only get in touch with our own
source of intuition and wisdom
when we no longer depend upon others
opinions for our sense of identity or
worth
we all tend to worship something
the question is will we worship the god
of opinion or the god of our heart
i found i had less and less to say until
finally i became silent
and began to listen
i discovered in the silence
the voice of god
now look it
you're going to attract to you
everything that you require
to manifest the idea in your mind
thoughts will come to you
it's your intuition that picks them up
and then act on them
and just because you've never gone there
before you've never done it before
that's okay
this is where courage comes in
this is where awareness
and wisdom comes in
see intuition is the mental faculty
if go back to our slide here for a
moment scott
intuition is here
in our conscious mind
it's one of our intellectual factors
we have perception
the will
reason
imagination
memory
and
intuition
right here
now intuition is that mental faculty on
a conscious level we pick up thoughts
that are flying our way
they're flying our way
what are they
it's energy that's in harmony with you
you've got on the frequency
of this good that you desire
and you're going to start attracting and
that's what kierkegaard said we got to
start listening
we listen with our emotions let's pay
attention to what's coming our way i
didn't like the idea that
when you've lived for so long you've got
to cut out you've got to stop i thought
hell i don't like that idea at all
um
first of all i think where
where i believe we're here to do god's
work god's work is creation
you know
uh
expansion fuller expression greater
goodness
um
and if we're going to do that
we're going to be working at it
all the time we're here on this planet
we never stop so age should have no
bearing on it mm-hmm
i had a gospel of people ask me when we
started to build this place we
put a couple of million dollars into
this and somebody said how old are you
and i think i was probably 83 when they
started to break ground
they said you're 83 and you're gonna
spend two million dollars building a
studio
and i said yeah like
why not
i mean
you see we let things that
really have no concern we let them
bother us we let them control us
age is a dumb thing to let control you
it's our thinking that controls
everything
that's the one point every great leader
agreed on we become what we think about
well what's a person thinking
i'm thinking if i get old i got to stop
well then you'll stop
or i'm thinking well if i've been here a
long time i've got a lot of experience i
want to utilize that experience to keep
me going as long as i am here there's
a boss and there's a leader leader get
people excited about improving the
quality of whatever it is themself their
work whatever they're doing
people follow leaders because they want
to
people don't follow leaders because they
have to that becomes a form of
dictatorship yeah and that never works
the great leaders people want to follow
and
leaders inspire you leaders pull the
very best out of you leaders know how to
look inside and bring the best of you to
the surface cause you to look at the
higher side of your own personality
what the world always is looking for its
leader like it's silly to ask who's
going to lead the leader is going to
lead
and the leader just automatically
emerges if they threw 50 of us into a
committee
and say you don't elect a leader you may
elect one but the leader is going to
lead and it probably isn't the one
that's elected
yeah that's so true and the reader knows
how
they know how to get the best out of
people i want to talk to you about where
you're going and what you want to do
with your life
you see most people never go after what
they want because they don't know every
step they have to take to get there
i want you to think of a person going up
the side of a wall of ice
now the only rule for reaching a goal
that you have to know
is knowing where you're going
and knowing that you're going to get
there you do not have to know how you're
going to get there
now pay attention to this for a moment
imagine the climber has all his
equipment he's got his crampons he's got
his climbing rope his hardware his ice
axes
how does he get to the top
he's standing on the ground
and he's looking at maybe a hundred foot
vertical wall of ice he looks up and he
has absolutely no idea the path that
he's going to take he just sees himself
at the top
he reaches up and he puts one pick in
and then another pick then he raises one
foot and then the other now he's not
standing on the ground any longer
he's suspended on the wall on a vertical
wall of ice that goes up for a hundred
feet
he adapts to the changes that is taking
place in his environment and then and
only then does he see the next step
and he moves this pick then this pick
then this foot then this foot
now that's how he gets to the top a step
at a time and that's how you're going to
get to your goal you just have to know
the first step to take and when you take
that step
you're going to find that your
conditions your circumstance and
environment will change then you see
how you have to make the next step it's
a matter of adapting all the time you
only have to know two things
you have to know where you're going and
you have to know that you're going to
get there you've got to see it in your
mind now this is the beautiful scenario
this is what it's all about save that in
your mind and think of it often think
every time you think of your goal and
you're trying to figure out how you're
going to do it think of that vertical
wall of ice
what's the next step that's all you
really have to know one step at a time
and you'll get to wherever you're going
that's how hillary got to the top of
mount everest hello there and welcome
you know almost everyone has a great
idea
and they're going to execute the great
idea i have all kinds of people come to
me i've got a great idea i'd like to
share with you
what they do is they want me to execute
their idea
why don't they execute their idea
when you get a real good idea you should
act on it
people have ideas of starting a business
i've started a number of different
businesses
question is where to start
you start where you are and you start
with what you've got
that's all you need
when you start where you are and with
what you've got and you bring your mind
to focus on that idea you will attract
everything to you that you need
you are taught seek first this kingdom
in its righteousness and all these
things will be given to us
see when you learn to focus on something
you get on a frequency
and when you're on that frequency you
start to attract whatever you want
you may not have any money you may not
have the resources that you need to
execute to build it into something big
that doesn't matter
all the resources that you need to do
anything you want to do is already here
but you've got to get in touch with them
you've got to get in harmony with them
and boom you'll rush them into your life
you'll attract the money the people the
thoughts the things everything you need
you'll attract to you
so where do you start
you always start where you are and you
start with what you've got
don't be looking at what you don't have
think of what you do have fall in love
with your idea and get it rolling now if
you tell yourself a lie often enough
you're going to start to believe it
and way around 1900 william james said
believe and your belief will create the
fact
it's got to be believed you've got to
believe it
and there's no belief it ain't going to
happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea
and that makes all kinds of things
happen when you believe it
there's no quitting you never quit
it doesn't matter what happens you don't
quit
quitting is never an
option i
the people that quit
they never really bought into the idea
in the first place
see you've gotta you you get it on three
levels the second you think of something
you've got it intellectually
when you get emotionally involved you've
got it on a spiritual or emotional level
well then that expresses itself through
the body body's just an instrument of
your mind
and
so when you're really buying into it you
literally fuse with it neville said you
fuse with it
and this causes all kinds of things to
happen you're dealing with electronics
you're dealing with energy
like the second you think something
that's all you need see you live on
frequencies you think on frequencies
your phone operates on frequencies
and it's like magic
um you're you're in romania are you
right i'm in toronto yes
if i've got your number on my phone i
could take a picture or something hit it
like that you've got it in romania
simultaneous with me sending it because
when you get into the mind there isn't
any time or space
it's just immediate
yeah well
you're living on frequencies
now when you think of something what
you've done is you flipped your brain
onto a higher frequency the very fact
you can see it is all the proof you need
to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency
and then you will attract whatever is on
that frequency all the good you need to
manifest the idea overcoming fear is one
of the greatest
moves a person can make
first of all we have to ask yourself
what causes fear fear is caused by
ignorance not knowing
and
if we're going to go and do anything new
if we're going to break out of a
paradigm if we're going to change habit
patterns we're wandering into an area
we've never been
and you know fear stops most people
you'll find people afraid to talk to a
stranger
you'll find individuals afraid to stand
up and ask the question in front of
other people you'll find salespeople
afraid to make a sales call afraid to
ask for the order
stop and think of how confining that is
a person is putting themselves into a
small cell but it's in their own mind
the doors aren't locked
they can open and you can walk away to
freedom
if you learn to overcome fear
when you face fear it leaves you
face the thing you fear and it'll leave
you that's really the secret of it
in fact if you hold yourself back
because of fear your life actually comes
to a stop because nothing gets better
than it is
you've got to be
courageous
now
courageous people aren't without fear
courageous people are the ones that face
their fear i think eddie rickenbacker
pointed that out the great pilot
don't let fear stop you make up your
mind you're going to step out and do it
stop and think of the number of people
that are in jobs that they don't like
and they're afraid to leave or people in
relationships that are destructive and
they're afraid to leave
this is a terrible way to live and it's
not necessary
it's just caused by ignorance and when
we step out and do something we gain an
awareness we develop an understanding
and like that the fear is gone
make up your mind that fear is not going
to stop you from doing the thing you
really want to do
step out and do it today when i was 26 i
had a man that sat down with me
and he said why don't you change the way
you're living
it never entered my mind that i could
and looking back
and thinking about i think there's all
kinds of people wandering the planet
there's all kinds of athletes
that are not getting the results they
want and they don't know they can change
them
right only one person can continue
there's only one person in the whole
universe that can change bob and that's
bob
yeah there's only one person who can
change dave and that's dave
you know we get inspired by other people
we get help from other people but we've
got to do it ourselves and he gave me
think and grow rich and he said if you
do exactly what i tell you you can give
anything you want well i didn't believe
that
but he was so adamant about i believed
he believed it
and so
i started to listen to him
and i set a goal i wanted some money i
wanted 25 000
now this was in 1961 so it was more
money than it is today but i didn't even
know anyone with 25 000 he said listen
write it on a card keep reading the book
keep doing what i tell you so i started
to hear people talking about earning
money
and
there was one guy said there's good
money cleaning floors you said you
should clean floors well i wasn't proud
i'd clean floors
and he said but you should do it for
yourself not for somebody else so he
told me where i could buy a used war
machine some buckets and mops but i had
to borrow a thousand dollars well i was
at the point where nobody wanted to
touch me with money and i often say i
wouldn't have lent it to me right
because i wouldn't pay it back not that
i didn't want to i just couldn't
but i found a guy and he lent me the
thousand dollars
when you when you bought excuse me
because i have a question because i know
you when you borrowed that thousand
because you owed people money already
you explained that to people you know
you were just finding yourself but did
you have a different feeling about when
you borrowed this thousand that quite
possibly you were actually gonna be able
to just to pay this back this time do
you know something if i hadn't had that
feeling i wouldn't have got the money i
got it from a guy i knew his name al
kiper he was running and i didn't know
him he had a trust company it was like a
bank on danforth avenue in toronto
and
i went in
i read a book where it says go to one
bank and then we'll give you go to
another one well i ended up sitting in
his office and he said what do you want
this money for son
and i told him i was going to build a
cleaning company it was going to be big
i had a dream
and
i had to explain it all to he said i
think you'll do it i'm going to lend you
the money
faith but i knew when i was doing this i
had a picture i had a dream you see yeah
and
within a year i was earning 175 000 a
year
i had my building up to 15 000 a month
working for myself in less than five
years we were working in toronto
montreal boston cleveland atlanta and
london england i had my own company
opening offices all over the place why
most people
don't get what they want out of life
is it well they don't know what they
want
that's right you see
i got this
and then i got earl nightingale's
condensed narration of this on a long
playing record
and i'd listen to that record over and
over and over again
one day
i was in the business in the cleaning
business i had sales people
and i had them listen to this record
every morning we listened to this record
and one day i said
you know i'd love to meet him
and i didn't know who earl night girl
was he was a voice on a record that was
it i didn't even know where he lived
and
a young guy that worked with me he said
no you wouldn't
he's if you wanted to meet him you'd go
and meet him
i thought damn he's right
so i phoned and i got an appointment
with him
now at the time he was the most listened
to man in the history of the
broadcasting industry he was a radio
broadcaster
and
not an easy guy to get to but i got to
meet with him for an hour i flew to
chicago
i spent an hour with him and when i was
leaving
i said earl
what's the big deal you know
i mean what's it all about he said
there's no big deal he said it's
it's very simple he says simply decide
what you love to do and then dedicate
your life to it he's the problem with
most people they don't know what they
love to do they never take the time to
sit and ask themselves what they're
doing is trying i think i can get her in
good money here i could do a good you
know it's breaking the earn some money
it's not what they love to do
well i was sitting there
now i had offices all over the place i
had a lot of people i was earning a lot
of money
and i i got excited because i knew
exactly what i wanted to do i want to do
what he was doing
and i made up my mind sitting in his
office
that would be
somewhere around 1965
that i was going to go back and i was
going to work with him
[Music]
and
in 1968
i moved to chicago i left my own company
i moved to chicago and i started to work
with we hear patience is a virtue
i suppose it probably is
but i think patience
real patience
is an expression of deep understanding
you see
everything happens when it's supposed to
happen
everything in this universe happens by
law
we set targets and we need things to
happen we need something to come or
someone to do something
and frequently we get frustrated because
it isn't happening when we think it
should happen
our problem is we're not thinking
we believe we're in charge we are not in
charge we are in charge of building the
idea and holding the idea everything
else happens automatic it happens by law
all ideas have a gestation or an
incubation period
i'm told when we plant a carrot in the
area of the world that i live it takes
approximately 70 days for that carrot to
grow
and manifest in form
when
the seed for the babies planted
it takes approximately 280 days
and we're usually patient we will wait
the 280 days why because we know it's
going to take approximately 280 days
well just because we don't know how long
it's going to take
doesn't mean that it isn't operating by
the same laws everything operates by law
so if we gain an understanding that all
the ideas in our mind will ultimately
move into form
that's what andrew carnegie taught
napoleon hill
carnegie was hill's mentor he said any
idea that's held in the mind that's
emphasized that's either feared or
revered will begin it wants to clothe
itself in the most convenient and
appropriate form available
you might want to listen to that two or
three times
burn it into your mind gain an
understanding of it
and you will know that whatever you're
working on takes a period of time
no one knows what the gestation period
is for an idea we only know we can
shorten it through concentration through
focus
and when you understand that you'll
become more patient and when you're more
patient you're living in a much more
beautiful vibration you'll be a more
pleasant person to be around you will
enjoy yourself more
patience
it's the result of understanding if you
really analyze your beliefs
you'll change them right i had a friend
one time i i was trying to figure out
where do beliefs come from how do you
because all religion and all science
will tell you
you got to believe it william james from
harvard 1900 he said believe in your
belief will create the fact
so belief is an interesting word you got
to believe it
and
i was having lunch with a mentor one
time and he said our belief system is
based upon our evaluation of something
frequently if we reevaluate a situation
our belief about that situation will
change
it was like bells were going off my head
because i was trying to understand
belief how do you change your belief
well he told me it's through
reevaluation and so i started to
evaluate myself
and reevaluate what i was doing
it took me nine and a half years but i
figured out why i changed and it was the
repetition of information thank you
you're in sports you know it's
repetition yep repetition repetition
well
but practice doesn't make you perfect
perfect practice makes you perfect
there's a big difference great point and
so
i found that the part of our mind that
controls our behavior
is not the part of our mind that gathers
information school deals with the part
of your mind that gathers information
and so we gather all kinds of
information and if we can remember it
they give us a test we pass the test we
get the degree and we're educated that's
not education at all
that is gathering information education
as hill pointed out comes from the latin
aduko meaning to reduce to develop or to
draw from within we have genius in us we
have absolute perfection in us
and what we have to do is learn how to
tap into that to let it out
but we have a part of our mind that
controls our behavior and that's where a
paradigm is and the paradigm literally
controls our behavior i don't care what
you're doing
if you're not altering the paradigm
you're not going to improve your results
there's so much about ourselves we never
learn
the part of our mind that controls us is
our intellect or our subconscious where
the paradigm is but we're trained to
live through our senses
we're trained to go by what we see hear
smell taste touch and we've got to
understand that we've got this genius
within us and if we will consciously
gain an awareness and understanding of
how to alter the paradigm that's
controlling our behavior
when we learn that we can start to
improve life just like that
and there's no end to what we're capable
of doing we're conditioned genetically
all mums dna and all dad's dna becomes
our dna there's two particles of energy
come together that's the moment of
conception 280 days later we make our
debut on the planet then we're
programmed by our environment because
our subconscious mind which is totally
deductive it has no ability to reject
the subconscious mind is immoral it's
like the earth it doesn't care what you
plant but it'll return what you plant
earl nightingale used a beautiful
example on the strangest secret he said
you can plant night shade a deadly
poison not a sixteenth of an inch away
you can plant corn as sweet food one
will grow with just as great in
abundance as the other and that's the
way your subjective mind works
you put the wrong idea in it will grow
put the right idea in it will grow
we have the ability to change what's in
there
we did not program it
it was programmed through genetic
history where the
confluence of a genetic pool that goes
back for generations that's at birth and
then environmentally
and we have the ability to alter all
that see any success i've had i've had
because i've got great mentors
and i'm a good student now until i was
26 i was a terrible student when i
picked up this book i become a great
student i've got thousands of books
i have an office at home in my home it's
got a couple of thousand books in it and
then i built a studio and i've got a
couple thousand bucks in the studio
i love reading
but
the success that i've enjoyed is because
of the mentors of the coaches i've had
i would do exactly what they tell me
and if i coach somebody today and they
don't do exactly what i tell them i
don't coach them anymore just like that
it's all over
it's not ready
well they're not they're it's not that
only that they're not ready but if i'm
going to coach somebody and they're not
doing what i tell them
i'm wasting my time and theirs too
now if they want to waste their time
that's their prerogative i'm not going
to waste my you know forgiving is one of
the most freeing concept anybody can
ever get involved with
most people look at forgiveness as
helping the other person
somebody hurts you somebody does you
wrong but you're going to forgive them
you're going to be kind to them it has
nothing to do with the other person it
has to do with yourself that's really
what it has to do see forgiveness is a
cleansing concept it's clearing the mind
of all negativity clearing the mind of
anything that might go wrong it's a very
freeing concept
if you were to do some harm to me
and i forgive you
you haven't got anything to do with it
it's i'm letting go of something that
was bothering me that's negative
and i don't want to hold on to that
forgiving
frees the one that's doing the forgiving
it's a phenomenal concept forgive means
to let go of completely abandon let it
go don't hold on to it
you know somebody does you wrong
you have to ask themselves ask yourself
wonder why they would do that there's
something bothering them
they're not really trying to hurt you
it's something that's bothering them let
it go
just forgive it forgive the idea
and i guarantee you you'll feel a lot
better one of the greatest hang-ups that
people have
is the belief in themself
they they suffer from something called
self-doubt
many years ago i read something
um
it was by um
ralph waldo emerson it was this essay on
self-reliance that's what we want to do
we want to rely on self and in that he
said there would come a time in every
person's education when they'd realize
that envy is ignorance and the imitation
is suicide so many people look at
someone that's doing very well possibly
in the same field they're in
and envy them
do you know what that's saying that's
saying i don't know
that
i have the same mental faculties you've
got i'm drawing on the same potential
that you're drawing on there is only one
mind
i don't know that
so i'm going to end you thinking you can
do something i'm not able to do the
truth is if you can do it i can do it
envy is ignorance it's not knowing that
and he said imitation is suicide
do you know that nothing in this
universe would move in the precise order
it moves in your absence
that's true everything in the universe
is essential
you take any part away from anything
it's not complete
and everything in the universe moves in
a very precise way so you see we
shouldn't even want to be like anybody
else because we are unique we are truly
unique there's something like about us
that
you'll never find in another person
we're unique and we've got the god-like
ability to think
now
what is self-doubt self-doubt is the
opposite of self-confidence
confidence comes from
understanding
like i would imagine you're confident
you can drive your car
in fact you're so confident that you'll
be talking to somebody on the phone
you'll get in the car you'll start the
car you'll drive and you'll drive maybe
four or five blocks not even be unaware
of what you've done it's all done
automatic your concentration is on the
conversation you're on now when you
first got in a car you couldn't do that
the car was probably jumping all over
the place and you thought you'd never
learn how to drive it but you learned
how to drive it now you're quite
confident you're confident that you can
get dressed when you get up in the
morning
when you were a little boy or a little
girl you couldn't do that you had to be
taught to do it
well you know self-confidence comes like
all confidence it comes with knowledge
and the more you study you the more you
understand who you are
the more confident you'll become in your
ability to do whatever it is you're
doing and you'll know that if you lack
confidence in an area it's because you
liked information in that area never
doubt yourself
and when you do understand that the
cause of that doubt
is not
lying within you it's in wrong thinking
it's in not understanding who you are
study yourself
self-study
will develop self-confidence and
self-confidence
eliminates self-doubt love is the
greatest thing
love what you do
i went to visit earl nightingale one
time way back in the 60s i'll never
forget it and i was leaving i felt i was
so grateful i had an hour of his time
and i said earl
what's the real secret i mean what's the
big deal well he said there isn't any
big deal about him and there isn't any
secret it's simply a matter of sitting
down and
determining what you really love to do
and then make a decision to dedicate
your life to it
man did i get excited
he said the problem with most people is
they don't know what to do and they
never make a decision to dedicate their
life to anything
i got so jazzed i knew exactly what i
would love doing i would love to do what
he was doing that made up my mind i
wanted to do it and i wanted to do it
with him and i made up my mind i would
make a commitment to that for the rest
of my life you know something that's
exactly what i've done
i love what i'm doing i love it i
absolutely love it now when you love
doing something you'll run baby and you
won't get weary you'll walk and you
won't get tired you know why you're a
free flow the energy is just freely
throwing through you
you are the greatest instrument then
that god's got you're here to do god's
work
what's god's word god's work is creation
god's the creator
you're creating god's image you've been
given creative faculties
fall in love with what you do and you'll
be creating great stuff wherever you go
love what you do
love the people that you're working with
fall in love with the idea of love at a
very early age we put a cap on awareness
and then we say now it's all about the
intellect
and so we've got
lessons in school and you got to
remember what's in the book and if you
pass the test you get the degree
there's all kinds of people walking out
of schools with degrees they're going
crazy by degrees and yet they can't find
work they're broke
you've got people that have a doctor
it's in economics and they're broke how
could that happen because they don't
know how to use the information they've
gathered the average individual is
self-serving they're they're they're
always focused on themselves i want you
to just pay conscious attention today
write a little note maybe that you fold
up on carrying your hand why do you do
that just to remind you that you want to
pay attention to everybody you meet what
are they doing
are they really trying to help other
people or are they really trying to find
help for themselves are they
self-serving or are they serving others
you're going to find the people that are
the best at serving others
they are the big winners in life
figure out how you can improve the
service you're rendering
now i'm probably a little older than you
so i've been running around the park for
quite a while longer than you
and i have learned one thing
really well in life
that my success my happiness is going to
be dependent on how good i get at
serving you or serving other people
i spend most of my time trying to figure
out how to help other people
i do
i don't spend much time you know
i get almost everything i want
almost everything i want there's very
few things i can't even think of
anything i want christmas birthday comes
along well i don't know
you know
send a donation in my name i like i
don't want anything
and it's got to a point where i just
want to serve others
so i want to do is serve others
now i'm a pretty happy guy
pretty healthy guy pretty wealthy guy
what have i done i have just learned how
to fall in love with the idea of serving
other people
our company's success is going to be
dependent upon how many people we can
serve and how well we serve them
we have a phenomenal staff of people in
proctor gallagher institute i choose to
believe that we have
i just i just love our staff
we have some of the most
phenomenal people
and we've got people come like we have a
guy
tommy collier the guy is a creative
genius he came he wanted to come to work
with us you want to work with us
i thought wow
guys so good
you will attract good people if that's
all you want to do just serve other
people that's what we do and we've got
everybody in the company that's where
they're going we've got some pretty
happy people very successful people and
all we did is focus on serving other
people companies that are enjoying the
most success they're the ones that
provide the most the best service
this is the way it works
it always has worked that way
and i'm inclined to believe that it
always will work that way
fall in love with the idea of serving
others you'll be very happy but you'll
also be very successful you should seek
failures
see if you're playing it safe you're not
going to win
if you're playing it safe
like that old saying you know you're
talking you're a little girl better to
be safe than sorry well that's a bunch
of crap it's not better to be safe than
sorry
it's by trying things that you figure
out how far you can go
you got to get outside the box
like it's reported edison
tried 3 000 ways before he built the
incandescent light he he said he didn't
fail 3 000 times he said there was 3 000
different steps to building a light bulb
well there's different steps to get to
where you're going and i really do treat
winning and losing exactly the same i do
not let it upset me
do you think that's a big part of why
you're so successful
well it's part of why i enjoy it
um yeah i think it is because i try
anything
like if if i'm into an idea
the idea of losing never enters my mind
see i have worked with giants
i had the good fortune of
working with sir edmund hillary
he was the first man to stand on top of
the world
and
i worked with him on three different
occasions
and the only difference in ed hillary
and bob proctor is in his his size now
he's gone now but he was a big man when
he shook hands with me his hand wrapped
right around mine i felt like a
dwarf
you know
and
in talking to him like it never entered
his mind he wouldn't get to the top of
the mountain but he failed in 1951 he
failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain now people had died
for centuries trying to do that
he said i knew if i could see it in here
i could hold it out here still a man
wrote that in the book
you can see it in your head you can hold
it in your hand
and that's right
and if you're not prepared to lose
you're never going to win because you're
always playing it safe
and there's no there's no reward in that
look at these two men do you know who
they are most people don't they're just
a couple of ordinary guys one they're
both gone now but one was an ordinary
beekeeper in auckland new zealand and
the other as sherpa guide from over
around nepal now there's mount everest
do you know for thousands of years
people had tried to get to the top mount
everest people died doing it it was
believed it couldn't be done
people tried but they didn't know how
and so they quit
there's a closer look at the mountain
and where they placed their flag they
planted that flag in the mountain now
this is the two of them after they come
down the mountain and you know something
when they started they did not know how
they didn't know how to get to the top
of the mountain and that's what stops
most people because they don't know how
as little kids we'd go mummy daddy i
want this and they said how are you
going to do that well as a little kid
you don't know how to do it but they did
it in 1953 on the 29th of may they were
the first two to get to the top of that
mountain they stood right in top of the
world
do you know there's been over a thousand
people do it since then i watched a
young woman on canadian television being
interviewed not very big
she just come back from going to the top
of mount everest and the reporter asked
her they said how does it feel now that
you conquered the mountain she we didn't
conquer the mountain that mountain can't
be conquered we conquered the
limitations that are within ourselves
j.c penney when he was 92 somebody asked
him
how are you doing
well he said my eyesight is fading me
but he said my vision has never been
better
[Music]
van gogh one time was asked how do you
do such beautiful work
he said
i dream my painting
and then i paint my dream
[Music]
vision
vision
where there is no vision the people will
perish
what is vision vision
is a
long-range view
of a multiplicity of things you want to
do
[Music]
now your purpose is why you're living
your vision then you want everything to
be on purpose your vision then is like a
funnel coming out of your head going off
out into the future it's a long range
picture of a multiplicity of things you
want to do
your goal is taking a bite out of your
vision
so sit and think i'm god's highest form
of creation i've got mental faculties
that go beyond the scope of my
imagination
and build a long-range vision
of all the magnificent things you want
to do
live with a vision
if you're not doing that now you're
missing something in life that's very
valuable
stop whatever you're doing right now and
totally relax and build a vision of
doing all kinds of things in the future
future they all blend in together but
they're all different and your life just
gets bigger and better and bigger and
better and bigger and better
that's the vision of your life
vision it's a beautiful picture it's
like a movie in your mind
a vision
you build the vision with your
imagination
not with your eyes
but with your imagination
see a person hasn't got this
where there is no vision the people will
perish it's so true
so true
television i quoted andrew carnegie a
few minutes ago
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered
begins at once to clothe itself in the
most convenient and appropriate form
available
depression
comes it starts out from ignorance doubt
and worry
i've got a chart i show it
doubt and worry
is on the negative side of life
understanding is on the positive side
don't worry comes from ignorance
understanding comes from knowledge
but you've got to study to get it
don't in worry are a psychic disease
it's an intellectual exercise
they're using their intellectual factors
to build a negative idea
and that's all they see
they take and internalize that and they
get emotionally involved with it it goes
from don't worry to fear
they've emotionalized the doubt or worry
turns into fear
the fear is in the emotional mind and
the emotion must be expressed through
the only instrument that can be
expressed through the physical body
so it moves a body into a state we call
anxiety
anxiety is never expressed anxieties
suppressed
the suppression turns to depression
they've all led up inside they
suppressed the fear
it turns into depression the depression
turns into disease
the disease turns into decay sinclair
lewis was right he said we don't die we
kill ourselves now what is the opposite
of all that you go from ignorance to
don't worry to fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration
go over on the other side
you go from understanding
to emotional state called faith
you just know it's going to move into
form because you understand the law
faith doesn't believe in something you
can't see strange thing about faith and
fear they both demand you believe
something you can't see
why would people choose fear over faith
because they're ignorant
so you go from understanding to faith
the faith manifests on the physical
plane not as anxiety as well-being
the well-being is not suppressed it's
expressed
and the expression turns to acceleration
you're building energy
and that is because there's no disease
you're at ease
and that turns into creation not
disintegration
it's all it's all a mental trip that
they're building
now they go to the doctor the doctor
gives them valium or some kind of drug
to cool them out
he gets them numb so they don't know
what the hell they're doing have you
ever thought of
failing
your way to success
think about that for a moment do you
know that anyone that enjoys any kind of
success feels their way there
that's right they do
i want you to think of this for a moment
see this little light here
someone gave me this as a gift this is a
replica
of the light that
edison built
and you know
he spent a long time before he got this
thing to glow he really did
and
[Music]
he started off because he had an image
of it in his mind that every time he
tried he failed
and he failed 3
000 times it's been said no i've never
really talked edison so i don't know if
that's accurate but i have an idea it is
3 000 failures now a reporter asked him
one time how he felt about failing 3 000
times he said i didn't fail 3 000 times
he's there with 3 000 steps to get to
where i'm going
you know if i were to tell you
all the sad stories about
it's got me to where i am
i would really spoil your week and
there's been some real sad stories i
think it might even make me cry again
but i've had so many failures that i
wouldn't even want to guess at it
i have i've blown everything i had three
different times
i never let it bother me much and you
know i have found that
every time i failed i moved closer to
the goal
you see if you knew how to do it now
you'd be going sideways
when you're going after a goal you're
going ahead
and because you're going where you've
never been you're going to make mistakes
you don't know it all you have
perfection within you and the objective
of life is to
bring that perfection to the surface
that's exactly what this guy did
well
you're going to make a lot of mistakes
bringing that to the surface
those mistakes
are steps to where you're going
i often tell sales people that are
afraid to make a call
just to get out there and make a call
and their objective isn't to sell their
objective is just make the call
if you make the call and you're afraid
and you do it
you're successful you've accomplished
what you want to do you made a call
and after you get comfortable making
those calls then you can start to polish
up your presentation
and odds are pretty good you'll start
making sales
and if you keep polishing up your
presentation and working at getting
better you're going to master
a thing called selling
but if you think
that you're going to enjoy great success
there's just one win after another
you're kidding yourself it just doesn't
happen i don't even know anyone that's
pulled that kind of a deal off
if they did they were cheating or lying
you don't get what you want you get what
you are you've got to become what you
want you've got to realize that the
minute you hold your mind in harmony
with the good you want
then you've already got it it's only a
period of time until it manifests in
physical form you've got it
intellectually and you can talk to
somebody about it you've got it
emotionally you can share your feelings
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form that's called the perpetual
transmutation of energy
that is a law the first law of the
universe do you have
any regrets for your life
no absolutely not
i'll tell you
i probably would have said yes
15 20 years ago
then what happened
i was watching johnny carson's show
the late show
and johnny carson wasn't there
george carlin the comedian was sitting
in for him
and
they're both dead now
vincent price a movie actor
was a guest he's gone too
but vincent price had
just shot a pilot
and of course they told the public on
television it's a new series well it
wasn't a new series at all they were
hoping it would turn into a new series
they shot a pilot if they got good
ratings then they'd shoot
a dozen more of them
right and
so after they went through the small
talk carl and says to him well tell me
vince
vincent tell me about our new your new
series
and vince says oh i think everybody's
going to love it
he said it's about a train and it's like
a magic train
is you can buy a ticket
to go back in your life
i would pay for that at any point you
want to start over
and he said when you get there i'm the
conductor on the train i stopped the
train now you off
and he said i think everybody'd like to
go back and start over at some point
don't you think so
i thought yeah i could think of a couple
of things where i could have started
over
and george carlin said
no i don't think so
he said if i went back and changed
anything that had happened in my life
i wouldn't be me
and i like me
i thought god what a perfect answer
no regrets everything that happened was
necessary to make me who i am to
premiere prepare me to do what i'm going
to do
and you see the crazy part about it none
of us know what we're going to do we
think we know right we've got to track
but
things happen that barrier to security
well there's a couple of them okay i
think there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time we're infants
all we can do is act and talk like the
people around us that's why we learn the
language we learned if there was 10
languages spoken in our home we'd learn
10 languages without any trouble
there's usually one and that's the only
one we ever learn we grow older and we
think well i couldn't learn another
language we could learn 100 if we wanted
to you can do anything but i think we're
conditioned we have a
real strong conditioning usually with
not some very good ideas
and then that that's the
the barrier that's inside is the one
that's outside of us says our
environment we have a tendency to act
like everybody around us
and if you think about this it doesn't
make a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95 of the people live their
entire life and never live the way they
want to live
you know that 95 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
north america okay the richest continent
in the history of the world they'll work
productively let's say for 40 of their
65 years okay and they'll end up with
hardly any money
there's got to be something wrong you
know don schuler the coach of the old my
miami dolphins
he said it's the start that stops most
people and he's right it is the start
that stops most people they're always
going to get ready to get set to get
going what we've got to do is boom just
like that move into action
see if you don't get started you're
never going to get finished
how do we do that
start early
i believe when you wake up you should
get up the second you wake up get your
feet hit the floor move into action
and you know you'd be wise if you sit
down at night before you go to bed and
write down
six goal achieving activities
now that isn't go to the store
go to the bank or
get to cleaning it's not that
these are goal achieving activities
write down six of them and when you wake
up in the morning you move into action
you know where you're gonna go you don't
even have to think about it
step into action and get on the first
one
when you get it done forget it and go to
the second one don't think about the
first one focus on two don't even think
about three when you get two done go to
three
but knock them off one at a time if you
don't get them all done just move them
over onto the next day
now that doesn't mean if you only get
three done that you have nine the next
day
there are three of the six that you're
gonna do the next day
six goal achieving activities and when
you wake up in the morning move into
action on them quit holding yourself
back don't wait
and say well i really don't know how i'm
going to get started and the way will
show itself it just appears
i have found when you get started when
you move into action everything starts
to happen around you i have worked all
over the world i mean
all over asia china south america north
america europe
and i'm always asking people what do you
really want
and i have found
most people don't want to be really
wealthy
what they do want is they don't want to
have any financial concerns
if they want to buy a new suit they can
go get one if they want to take a trip
they can take the trip
if they
want a new car they can get the new car
they don't want to just run out and
spend or buy
they don't want to have any financial
concerns
two
they want to wake up in the morning
excited about how they're going to spend
their day
and the third
they want to mix with people
who are upbeat
and
creatively productive
these are the three things that people
really want
so in answer to your question if
somebody's watching
what's the first thing they should do
well
the first thing they should do is
understand why we have goals not just to
set a goal because most people don't set
goals right
they they're operating with a limited
level of consciousness so they're
thinking
hmm
if i
could get a little more money and if i
could get him to help me and her to help
me and this happened then i could do
this
maybe this is get a new car
what we've got to understand is we're
trading our life for our goals
literally trading our life
would you trade your life for a car
or a house i don't think so
so it's got to be something really
meaningful
and we're not taught to think this way
we should sit down
and don't give any thought to where the
money is going to come from where the
help's going to come from
it's what do you really want
like ed hillary was a beekeeper in
auckland
that story
he wanted to climb mount everest it had
never been done people died trying to do
it
he went in 51 and failed he went back in
52 and failed in 1953 he stood on top of
the mountain with tenzing norgay
but he didn't know how to get there
until after he had got there
edison didn't know how to illuminate the
world until after he had done it
the wright brothers were bicycle
mechanics in dayton ohio
no one believed you could fly
they had been trying it for years
but they saw it
but they wanted to do it
they didn't know how and they couldn't
tell you until after they had done it
now the first flight only lasted 12
seconds
and the naysayers said yeah but they
only were up there for 12 seconds they
said we not only got up there we kept
the damn thing up there for 12 seconds
so when a person sets a goal
they've got to say
what could i want
if i just let my mind rock just wander
use my imagination how do i really want
to live that's what they should be doing
most people don't use their imagination
constructively most people use their
imagination destructively they imagine
what they don't want
we've got to consciously and
deliberately imagine what we do want
if we will take and sit down with a pen
and ask ourself what do i really want
what do i really want
and write it down
and then
make a written description of it in the
present tense
writing causes thinking thinking creates
an image
and you get these images going you're
building a vision in your mind
it's the visionaries that change the
world
think of that
the fact that i can sit and look into
this camera
and you can sit and look at me on your
phone
or on your
tv or on your laptop
that was the result of somebody's vision
do you know everything you've got the
clothes you wear the house you live in
this microphone that's in front of me
it was all the result of somebody's
vision
it's not an accident you and i have a
marvelous imagination
and everything starts
with a vision
van gogh was asked how he did such
beautiful work he said first i dream my
painting and then i paint my dream many
years ago i read a book by terry cole
whitaker it was a classic what you think
of me is none of my business
think of the amount of time that is
wasted on negative energy wondering what
other people think of you
what they think of you really doesn't
make any difference it's what you think
of you that makes a difference so as you
go through the day
don't
worry about what other people think of
you
just say
i'm all right i'm god's highest form of
creation see this line
that's called the terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it
and on the other side of the terror
barrier is something we call freedom
and you know
very few people get through that terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone
there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now i'm going to show you
why people experience buyer's remorse
when they buy something they really want
and then they back away
where they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear
causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the x represents
the unknown
factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we have the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the paradigm
now here's an important point
the paradigm controls the vibration of
this thing we call our body
our body is a molecular instrument
that's really what it is it's a massive
molecules and a very high speed of
vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts
that harmonize with the vibration
they're in so they feel comfortable they
may not like the results but they're
comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting x-type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
x type conditioning x-type vibration
the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from left
field boom
in comes a y type idea what is the y
type idea the y type idea represents
anything that you might want to do that
you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs
sell the house buy the farm whatever it
may be
ask the little girl for the date
ask the guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea
but as long as the y idea is just in the
conscious mind it's just going to be an
intellectual exercise it's never going
to happen
so how do we make it happen
well
that's when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power flows in
and what do they do they got the y type
idea
now for some strange reason they know
that they've got to get emotionally
involved if they're going to act on that
idea they don't understand what's going
to happen but clearly understand this
your central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a super computer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mind that's when
all hell breaks loose
because the body moves in to an extra xy
vibration it's not in the x vibration
not the one that we're comfortable with
may not like the results but we're
comfortable no on a conscious level
everything's going crazy on a conscious
level we experience doubt that doubt
turns into an emotion called fear and
that fear is expressed through the body
as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like
at least they're comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going beyond
where you're at going to a new level i'm
going to tell you something when i set a
goal
if if if it doesn't scare and excite me
at the same time i know i'm going in the
wrong direction
now i also understand
that my paradigm is going to try and get
me to bounce back to where i was it
doesn't want me to move ahead
i don't want to live there
i lived there for the first 26 years of
my life and for the last 50 i've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and i want you to do the
same thing understand what i've just
said i'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the y
idea
that moved their body into a different
vibration on a conscious level they're
experiencing some crazy stuff they start
to doubt their ability will never be
able to pay for it they experience fear
the fear expresses itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that terror
barrier and you're right back
oh i might not be earning my chair but i
know what it is
i
i would love to move there but i'm
comfortable here i think i'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't do you know what to do say i'm
going to get rid of all that i
understand it's there but i don't want
any part of it and i'm going to go
crashing right through that terror
barrier
now does that get rid of the x energy no
the x energy
is still there
you see but at least you're over into
freedom you made the move you did it and
if you continue to feed the right
information into your mind keep feeding
that y idea keep getting emotionally
involved in the y idea you're there
you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier i'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did joseph campbell say
so true
the cave you fear to enter
holds the treasure you seek many years
ago
i read where napoleon hill
pointed out that the imagination is the
most marvelous
miraculous
inconceivably powerful force
that the world has ever known
[Music]
and you know
the average individual uses the
imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
coming
let's begin to use our imagination the
way god meant it to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty
that we
possess and we can build anything we
want with it
i want you to wander around your home or
possibly your office
and take a look at all of the
conveniences that you have there
that you didn't have
let's say two years five years ten years
ago
25 years ago
do you know that every one of them
without exception was first created
in the mind of one individual with their
imagination
do you know you can use your imagination
to go into the future and bring it into
the present
that's what all highly successful people
do
they see where they want to go
and then they act like the person they
want to become
it was william james from harvard's
advice
he says is the actor's technique act
like the person you want to become how
do you do that
but you use your imagination of course
you see it's a strange
phenomena
but the greatest gift we've got
is used
very well
up till the ages of four or possibly
five
the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination they're building wonderful
pictures in their mind
but then they get to school and wham
like that it comes to an abrupt halt
it's called not paying attention
daydreaming
well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see
we can see hear smell taste touch
therefore our physical benefit as long
as we're living in a physical body and
corresponding with the material world we
will use our sensory factors
but you know i have a couple of little
dogs at home that can hear see smell
taste and touch
we've got higher faculties
the will
memory
intuition
reason
and imagination
these
marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now
don't let your present results have
anything to do with this
just what you want
and it's with your imagination that you
will build it
everything that we have the camera that
i'm speaking to right now
was first created in the mind of one
individual
[Music]
think of how our world's changed
you see
we were gifted
with these higher faculties
we're god's highest form of creation
we were created in god's image we were
given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population
[Music]
it's almost inconceivable that we people
would wander around with so much power
and potential
and squander it
see the average person literally tiptoes
through life hoping they make it safely
to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
i think we have giant corporations and
little weak creative departments
the primary reason for that is
the average individual
really does not believe that they're
creative
i think
everyone's creative and no one is more
creative than another
it's just that some have chosen to use
their creative faculties to a greater
degree than others
imagination
your imagination
what do you want
how do you really want to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power that is flowing to and through you
a creative
unadulterated power
it can be photographed leaving your body
way back in the 30s simeon curling the
russian photographer
perfected a form of photography where
you can actually photograph a person's
body and you will see the energy glowing
from them
well that energy flows into your mind
and it's the images you build in your
mind that's going to dictate the
vibration that this instrument you're
living in is in
and the vibration on a conscious level
is called feeling
make certain that you exercise your
imagination daily build beautiful images
in your mind of how you want to live and
then hold those pictures there and live
that way
the imagination
the greatest nation in the world the
imagination
you've got one
it's a marvelous creative tool
it deals with the invisible side of your
personality
you see no one will ever really see you
they'll only see your body and they'll
see you the great work that you do
make certain that your work is great
work
and if you keep your imagination alive
keep it active
you're going to have a phenomenal life
you know life can get better
every day and it will get better every
day
through the proper use
of your
imagination
what a wonderful idea
is bob proctor thank you
dr maxwell maltz wrote a book back
around 1960
it was called self-image psychology
psycho-cybernetics it's a phenomenal
book
he said it was the greatest discovery of
his generation
he was a cosmetic or a reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have
been a nose job or removed a terrible
scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality
but he noticed with others he would make
a phenomenal physical change and there
was no change in their personality and
that led him to postulate that we have
two images we have the one that's coming
back from the mirror but we've got an
inner image and that inner self image is
literally controlling our life
you will find people that have a very
poor self-image or low self-esteem they
won't look you straight in the eye
they're afraid to shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they go
through life hiding from life
they don't like themselves they don't
know themselves
do you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationship
change their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you
there's something phenomenal about you
do you know when i began to study this
material
57 years ago i had very poor self-image
i had low self-esteem
i took dumb jobs i never earned any
money i never had fun i had poor
relationships and as i started to study
start to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
i've got friends all over the world
today i earn millions of dollars
i'm in my 80s and i get as much energy
as a person in their 30s
you see
when you start to understand really who
you are you're god's highest form of
creation there's things about you that
just about blow your mind as you start
to study and really understand them
you'll walk a little taller you'll stand
a little straighter and you know
something you'll enjoy a whole lot more
of life you've got to wake
up you see
all we're ever going to get is awareness
we've already got everything
the only thing we lack is the awareness
of what we've got
we're god's highest form of creation
there's nothing on the planet that will
equal us
well
that's all we're that's all any of us
are after that's all the problems in the
world come from ignorance
that's the purpose of life overcome
ignorance
develop awareness the only way to
overcome ignorance is through knowledge
and the only way to get the knowledge is
to study
most people they finish school close the
book saying
that's over i'm never going to open
another book as long as i live
they're screwed it's all over napoleon
hill in think and grow rich wrote an
entire chapter on decision
most people never make decisions they
have a difficult time with it why is
that
i think they have a difficult time
because their parents made decisions for
them until they were too old
and they never learned how to make them
you know the one thing that i did with
my kids i never made a decision for them
they didn't like it they'd say come on
don't do that to me i said no what do
you think you should do and i'd leave it
at that
decision making is a phenomenal concept
and you're going to find out as he
points out in here that successful
people make decisions very fast and they
change them very slow if and when they
change them at all and he said the
people that have difficulty in life make
their decisions very slow and then
change them fast and often
and you know decision making is a funny
thing you and i think on frequencies if
we can see a bunch of lines and we're
thinking on a frequency
and we're on this frequency here and
we'll say i'm going to do that
when this changes this is never going to
change until you get up on this
frequency see the good that you're after
is on a higher frequency than you're
operating on a greater awareness and if
you're down here and you're thinking
here on this frequency and the good you
want up here you got to get your mind up
there how do you get up there make the
decision be there and that's really what
you have to do the second you make a
decision you flip your brain onto a
different frequency and you start to
attract things to you that you couldn't
you'd never get without making the
decision see someone woke me up that's
all i want to do with someone else what
the man said to me the first guy he said
you can have whatever you want
well you know they
you get thinking that you can get out of
the box that's where you've been given
an imagination to get out of the box
it's with your imagination that you
build images of what you want and if you
can build the image you can do it you
can hold it in your head you can hold it
in your hand
when we understand that
like i would imagine this goes out to a
lot of athletes
well they can they can have anything
they want they got to pay the price
and when doubt comes in kick it out you
can't afford the doubt if i want to do
something i find somebody that's already
done it
and then i do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow
i
i don't read novels i don't watch movies
um
i'd watch documentaries or things like
that where i can learn
and
i'm only interested in
studying
something that can cause me to become
more of what i'm capable of being
see i think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with our life
and
that's all i want to do
i'm really good at what i do
i could walk by a person in the hall
like that i could tell them exactly what
they're like i could read their energy
like a book
everything goes on the inside shows the
outside see
we're gifted with with faculties of the
mind that the average person knows
nothing about you have intuition the
will reason imagination perception
memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life
we go through school never learn
anything about it like you'll hear
people say they have a bad memory
there's no such thing as a bad memory
everybody has a perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it
our imagination
your imagination is the most magnificent
he hill said it's the most marvelous
miraculous inconceivably powerful force
the world's ever known i can use my
imagination to project myself into the
future and bring the future into the
present and start living there
you work from the imagination you don't
work to it
you work from it backwards from the
result yeah you know the people you
surround yourself with have a phenomenal
impact on your life i think it was carl
meneger from the medicare foundation one
time said
environment is more important than
heredity
the people were surrounded by have a
greater bearing on our life and our
success in life
than what's built into the genes at
birth there's genetic conditioning
there's environmental conditioning well
this environmental conditioning goes on
all the way through life
you will find as you improve the quality
of your life improve your thinking
you're going to attract a different
group of people into your life and they
are going to add to your life
see the people we're surrounded by
their thinking is going right into our
mind
we want to mix with people who are
really making it happen take a look at
your five people that you're with most
often
and ask yourself
if i have children would i want them to
grow up be like them if the answer is no
you better start looking for some new
friends if the answer is yes you're
already in the right circle of people
think about what i'm saying
the people we're surrounded with have a
phenomenal impact on our life and help
make us who we are william james from
harvard said believe and your belief
will create the fact
all things are possible if you believe
well you know i studied for a long time
i started to study this book think and
grow rich and he talks about belief in
here he says you're not ready for what
you want until you believe you can get
it
i found that the
only two sources of reference we could
go to to find out anything about
yourself is science and religion
they all say you've got to believe
so i get figured out
how do you how do you believe
how do you change a belief
interesting subject because i'm going to
tell you something
your results are nothing but the
manifestation of your belief system
well our belief system now listen
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something and frequently when we
re-evaluate a situation our belief about
that situation will change
let me repeat that
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something
frequently if we re-evaluate a situation
our belief about it will change
i began re-evaluating who i was i
started to study i never stopped
studying and i found as i reevaluated i
had a much higher opinion of myself i
found out things about me that i would
have never believed if you had told me
the power that's locked up within us the
marvelous system we've got you know the
blood circulates through your veins
every 33 seconds through hundreds of
miles of passageway bang just like that
colors all the food in and all the
garbage out stop and think of the
central nervous system it's the most
complex electrical system in the world
and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around you
we have awesome powers and it's all
based on what you believe about you
sandy gallagher is my business partner
love her
she is really good she was going through
a very tough time personally
a number of years ago
we were in phoenix we were doing a
seminar
i had to leave
catch a plane somewhere
and she said before you leave could we
get together maybe for a cup of coffee
could you um
i want to talk to you and i said sure
so we went across the road to a coffee
shop
and we were sitting there
and she said could you give me two or
three ideas that i could do every day
that would help me through this i said
sure i didn't know what i was going to
tell her but i knew i'd tell her
something
so i said every day
i want you
to take a pen
and write down every morning write down
10 things you're grateful for
but you've really got to be grateful
you've got to feel it you're really
grateful
then i want you
to send love to three people that are
bothering you
they're bothering you you don't like
them
they've got nothing to do with it you're
thinking bad thoughts about them you're
putting yourself in a bad vibration send
love to three people that bother you
and then
take five minutes
and be quiet
just be perfectly quiet and ask for
guidance for the day
everybody in our company does that every
day
she started to do it like that
everything changed
in fact
my assistant gina who's been with me
over 30 years
she was working in phoenix and i phoned
gina i told her what i wanted within an
hour she had a pad printed at kinko's
and had it
the ten things from one down to ten you
know
send love to three people and bother you
be quiet for five minutes
sandy was going to hawaii with her
sister and her mother the next day
she got pads made for both of them and
every morning they started to do that it
changed every one of their lives
we give that out now in a lot of our
seminars and we train the audience to do
it
start every morning write 10 things that
you're grateful for
send love to three people to bother you
be quiet for five minutes and ask for
guidance for the day
it's a winning form you see the
beautiful truth is you've already got
everything you need inside
you don't have to get it
you don't have to follow the pattern
that our formal educational institutions
teach us
you don't have to read all the books
that's unnecessary
i think madame montessori put it very
well she said we shouldn't send a child
to school
as if they're an empty cup and we expect
them to fill the cup
she's the truth is the cup's already
full
school is to help draw what's already
there
you see you and i are god's highest form
of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will even come close to us
things you know you and i are the only
creature on the planet that is totally
disoriented in our environment
all those other little creatures they're
completely at home in their environment
they blend in
we don't
we're totally disoriented
and that is because we have the ability
united of creating our own environment
now think of what that means
that means that you and i can literally
create the life we want
as i said when i first heard that i did
not believe it
but i knew the man that was giving me
the advice believed it and that man was
raymond douglas stanford one of my very
first mentors have you ever spent any
time wondering how does everything
happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does but
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this
in fact at times it almost drives me
crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud grown and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio
i'm sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're
greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring
they're always red in the fall and
greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship
and you might be walking up a plank just
right straight up and you go off the
ship sometimes you're going right down
that ship goes way up in the air and it
comes way down very high very low tide
now some place the tide's not very big
they do have a tide but not too high not
too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you think about this do you know that
everything in this universe happens in
an exact way
an exact way
not by chance but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states
actually asked dr warner von braun
who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring them back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew he had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with
the precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law
when you and i get in harmony with the
law now we do that odds are pretty good
we should understand them but when we
get in harmony with the law then i'm
going to tell you it's just smooth
sailing
success
happens
[Music]
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now i've been doing that for the last
58 years i'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but i don't
understand them as well as i want to or
would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here
i'll have to talk to you about this book
that'll be another talk
study the laws
find out what they write what they're
like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win
ever notice that some people seem to
want to hang on to stuff that is
bothering them they're forever talking
about it they don't want to let it go
they've had a a failure at something and
it's dwelling they can't get over it
they just can't get over it or somebody
said something nasty to them they don't
want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of
it you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to why would you
hold on to anything that's not serving
you now i want you to think about this
i'm not going to talk about a lot about
this today because i don't think i have
to i just want to let you know that if
you're holding on to something that does
not serve you
you are making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation
it's you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
you know the beautiful part about having
an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you right now i'm standing in
the middle of my library this is my
favorite place you know earl langdale
said if you surround your mind with
greatness some of it's going to rub off
well hopefully some of it is rubbed off
on me i have maybe three or four
thousand books here on the shelf they're
all in alphabetical order uh by author
they're all catalogued so i know where
to find something just like that i go by
authors more than the title of the book
do you know that
when i started studying these books i
really didn't know very much about
anything i had two months high school i
was 26 years old i had a bad work record
a bad attitude
and virtually no experience
and you know in a relatively short
period of time my income went from four
thousand to 175 000 a year then it went
over a million i like there's a saying
on all of your seminars on the tickets
uh
if you have to borrow money for this
do it it may be the last time
you're doing it listen
when i when i read this
i owed everybody i knew money
but the guy that
told me he said don't clean officer for
somebody else do them for yourself and
he told me where i could buy a used
floor machine and some buckets and mops
it was going to cost 980
i mean i didn't know anyone would lend
me money because i never paid them back
not that i didn't want to i just never
had any money
well i searched and searched and
searched and i found a guy that lent me
a thousand dollars
so when somebody tells me they can't
borrow money i know that they haven't
tried
i think anybody can borrow a thousand
dollars somewhere
and that's what i did
and i turned it into a multi-million
dollar organization
i sat down one day with my pen
in this business i said i'm going to
build a company that operates all over
the world we operate all over the world
so if you have to borrow money
borrow the money
but get into the business
actually do it although you cannot
change conditions or circumstance
you don't have to let them control you
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside
you know
and
unfortunately i don't think many of us
have been raised to really understand
that yeah
and it's a lack of understanding that's
causing all our problems we are the only
creature on the planet
that's totally disoriented in her
environment
all the little squirrels the birds
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in
you and i are totally disoriented in our
environment we've been given the mental
faculties to create our own environment
however we go right through school we've
never learned that
we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them how to
develop them we have perception the will
reason imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words
they're actually mental faculties that
we can use
to take control over our world and to
create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised to live
through by what we see hear smell taste
and touch our physical senses and we've
been raised to be controlled by what's
going on outside
as little kids will you listen to what
i'm telling you will you look at this
you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are
but it really tells us where our mind
was at for a few minutes three weeks ago
got nothing to do with who we are
so i think we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably
clear understanding of who they are and
what they're capable of doing but
the ones that do are in the minority the
future must become the present in the
imagination
of the one who had wisely and
consciously create circumstances
i think right now everybody wants to
create circumstances because they don't
like the ones they find themselves in
but you see you cannot change the
circumstance you find yourself in
you can only change your perception of
them and when you do that you change the
circumstance so we say here the future
must become the present in the
imagination of the one who would wisely
and consciously create circumstance
we must translate vision into being
[Music]
thinking of into thinking from
imagination must center itself in some
state and then view the world from that
state
see yourself where we want to be and
then be there
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world
of fulfilled desire
that is so cool
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire
so what are we doing we're building a
goal and then we see ourself already
having accomplished the goal
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire already got it i don't have to
get it i've already got it
that's an intense perception
of the world of fulfilled desire in
other words you got it it's here now
think
are you thinking from the end or you're
thinking of the end if you're thinking
of the end your thing is way out there
if you're thinking from the end you're
part of it
see
the end result has already happened in
our mind
we're creative beings we're god's
highest form of creation
we can create in our consciousness the
kind of person we want to be and then be
that person and that's what he said here
we must
translate vision into being
so we don't just visualize it we be it i
set a goal in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had
left the night guild conak corporation
and decided that i was going to do this
because i didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate all over the world i got a call
last night from mikey about nine o'clock
something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with some of
you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday in
restaurant
it was at dixie and uh just south of the
401 highway
in toronto
a man asked me if i would meet with him
he had a problem
and
i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier
and then to freedom you know in napoleon
hill's book
thing could grow rich
he said now right here we come to a
rather strange fact we tend to minimize
the things we can do the goals we can
accomplish and for some equally strange
reason we think other people can
accomplish things that we cannot and he
points out that there's a difference
between wishing for a thing and being
ready to receive them said no one's
ready for a thing until they believe
that they can acquire it the state of
mind must be belief and not mere hope or
wish now he goes under consciousness and
open-mindedness is essential to belief
closed minds will not inspire faith
courage orally i think reason is
probably
it's the one that's spoken about by
almost all the great leaders yeah um the
evolving complete unanimous agreement
that we become what we think about
it's our reasoning factor that enables
us to think
um
ford says thinking's the hardest work
there is which is the probable reason so
few people engage in it
dr ken mcfarland
is gone for a long time now but he was a
great educator down in kentucky he one
time said two percent of the people
think three percent think they think and
95 would actually rather die than things
now you know that sounds cute
but it's true
if you stop and listen
to what most people are saying
it's going to be fairly obvious they're
not thinking
if you stand back and watch what most
people are doing
it's fairly obvious they're not thinking
or they would never say or do what
they're doing
most people today have their television
on the news
and they're just
soaking up
all the stuff
that's going on that's dominating the
media right now
so they've become a play thing for
what's going on outside
and that's why they're living in such
fear
by consuming the media of whether it's
true or accurate or not true you're
you're being manipulated
yeah it's not a matter of whether it's
true or not
is this how you want to spend your life
just listening to that
um
that doesn't mean you should deny it it
doesn't mean that you should say well
that's all false
um
i don't know whether it's true or false
it's just bad news i don't want to be
involved in it yeah am i aware that it's
there well you'd almost have to be dead
not to be aware that it's there but that
doesn't mean you have to spend your time
thinking on that
i would much rather activate some of my
creative faculties and do something
that's constructive it's pretty well
known today there's a lot of fear in the
world
people are wondering what's going to
happen we've gone through many tough
times if you study history
i was born during the great depression
so i was of an age then i remember some
of the things as a little kid
then we went into a world war
and when the depression ended
it was sort of like a theater where the
lights were out it was empty but the
lights started to come up
and things started to get brighter
and of course they became very bright
so
the fear don't let fear control you fear
is a negative emotion
by following these principles you're
going to be on the other side of fear
where there's faith
there's a law of the universe called
polarity that law decrees everything has
an opposite
every negative has a positive
the truth is it's neither positive or
negative
it's our thinking that makes it so
everything just is we can make it what
we want
make up your mind now
you're going to go in the positive
polarity you're going to stay with me
because that's where i'm going
and there'll be a very bright future
let the fear go
it isn't necessary
the cause of it is ignorance the cause
of all fear is ignorance if you want
something you haven't got you got to
create a space for it if it's in your
own mind you've got to let go of
something
so what do we want to do to let go if we
want to let go of the image we've got
for the one we're going to build
now
i'm going to be honest with you when i
started to do this
i tested it just
i thought i wonder if this really work
and i found that it really worked
so i went all out
and
you start out by writing
the image that you want to hold
i'll tell you how i did it
i am
i took various people that i really
admired
and i took some of the qualities that i
really admired in them and i'd write
them down
i wasn't going to be like them but i was
going to develop a couple of these
qualities or habits when i was growing
up as a young guy it was during the
second world war
there was no men around no fathers
but one guy did have a father donny
miller's father
had was not well so he couldn't go to
the war
and
donny's dad had a heart attack or
something it was i think it was a heart
attack
and so we never went around his place
because his dad wanted things quiet
they'd come around our place but not
donny's place
i would watch
donny's dad walk up and down the street
you see him go way up the street later
on you'd see him come back
he was always well dressed and he had
the calmest walk
there was no rush just a very calm walk
i visualized myself walking like him
you'll very rarely ever see me rushing
anywhere there's no need of it you can
be calm
so when i built my self-image
i built it around certain things ray
stanford
always had money
i told you earlier i don't know how to
get into this thing now
always have some money
always
now
i hardly ever use it
because i really don't pay for very much
i get somebody in the company to order
whatever i want
but you see i never had any money ray
always had a role on him
he would have a role like that in his
pocket all the time
now there's about three thousand dollars
here there's not a boat there is three
thousand dollars here
you see
well
i only earned four thousand dollars a
year at that time three thousand dollars
would have been a ton of
money
but
everybody has different little quirks
i like to carry money
i and it's probably because i never had
any
and now
i have some money i want to carry it but
you see i started to do that before i
had any money
and i would take
and i would put
phony money in a roll but i would have
the right thing on the outside it was
the thickness of it
my mind didn't know the difference i
knew intellectually the difference and
then shortly i didn't even pay any
difference to that it was the feel of it
i did different things i watched
different people i saw how this person
did this and somebody else did that
i am
i read a lot
so i read a lot of great self-help books
and
i literally did what some of these books
suggested
it wasn't just sometimes i did it i
would follow it right to a t
um
you'll very rarely see me without a suit
on
that's part of the paradigm
that's part of the paradigm
i don't care what anybody else does how
they dress
i'm always going to be dressed
i am
mentally made up my mind one time i'd be
at least
if it wasn't the best dress one of the
best race people in the room
why did i do that
i did that because i was changing how i
saw me
how i saw me i had never gone to school
i had no money i had
dumb jobs
and today
along with sandy gallagher i have a
company operates all over the world
right here on my desk i have sitting
this little
hourglass
well you know i can't put anything where
that hourglass is until they get rid of
it
and we find that we want things to come
into our life but we don't create room
for them
nature
abhors a vacuum and i remember we were
sitting in the living room having a cup
of coffee
and just visiting and she said do you
mind if we go and sit in the kitchen
unless none at all
so
so i asked her i said
why do you want to sit in the kitchen
rather than she says i can't stand that
room i just hate living in that sitting
in that room she says i hate those
curtains that are on the window in the
dining room and the drapes on the front
window
and i said no you don't hate those mark
i said you only have attract things to
you that you love that you're in harmony
with i said if you really didn't love
them you get rid of them
but you say i'm going to put that
i'm going to put them there if i get rid
of them i said mark
if you had something to put there you
couldn't put it there because you've
already got something there and i said
that's when i started teaching the law
of vacuum law prosperity
certainly she went and got a chair and
got up and stood on she started to take
all these curtains down
well done he was wearing like a
stuffed peg he said what are you doing
and she says i'm getting rid of these
and she did
wasn't too long after i dropped in all
the furniture in the living room was
gone
it was like they were just moving into
the place
but then they got new curtains and then
they got new furniture and you know
everything in that business in that
house changed wasn't too long they're
only in business for themselves they're
both gone now but when they left
they were very well off they had a
beautiful place in florida they'd go to
a winter the family still runs their own
business
i mean it was it was such a beautiful
thing to see and it was all and i tell
the story in here because it was all
about the vacuum law and prosperity
well what have you got in your life that
you don't want
or that you don't like
or what is it that you've got that you
really want to get rid of
you've got to get rid of this stuff get
rid of it give it away
see nature truly does abhor a vacuum
when you make space for the good that
you desire that's when the good's going
to come most people don't make the space
for the good that they desire you know
the truth is your spiritual dna
is perfect
we hear a lot of talk about dna today
well if you get past all the nonsense
that's been programmed into our
subconscious mind from genetics and in
our environment
and get right down to the core of who
you really are
your spiritual dna is perfect and it's
that perfection that's seeking
expression with and through us
that's why we want things it doesn't
matter what we're doing we want more
now as a little boy i was taught by my
grandmother who pretty well raised me
that you should be satisfied with what
you've got
grandma was a dear woman she was like an
angel of god but she was wrong we should
never be satisfied with what we've got
we should be happy with what we've got
but never satisfied
you see dissatisfaction is a creative
state for our mind to move into
it causes us to want to do more
we should ask ourselves where those
wants come from do you know it's that
perfection within that keeps jabbing you
in the consciousness want this want that
if you're running you'll want to run
faster if you're jumping you want to
jump higher if you're selling you want
to sell more if you're singing you want
to sing a better tune
it doesn't really matter what you're
doing
you want to do it better
and the beautiful part of this is you
can i'm going to share something with
you that could change the course of your
life could make everything so much
better to do this to explain it properly
i'm going to tell you a little story it
goes way back 57 years
a man gave me this book he said bob do
exactly what i tell you and you can have
anything you want now when he said that
i was flat broke
i had six thousand dollars in debt i was
only earning four thousand dollars a
year the prospects of thing getting
better were pretty slim
i had two months high school formal
education i had absolutely no business
experience i was not in a good spot but
he said listen there are reasons why you
can't win bob he said if you do what i
tell you and study this book
is you're going to figure out how you
can now this is napoleon hill's book
think and grow rich he spent his whole
life studying 500 of the world's most
successful individuals and he found
there was a golden thread running
through their life and that's what's in
this book i've never stopped reading it
i then found a condensed narration of
the book by earl nightingale where earl
took and he condensed the whole thing
and he put it on a long playing record
and i would listen to that and listen to
it and listen to it in fact i had
started my own company and i used to
play the records to the sales people
every morning
well one morning it was very early
just finished the salesman and just
finished playing earl's record and i
said at the end of the meeting i said
man i'd really love to meet him one of
the sales people said no you wouldn't he
said what do you mean i wouldn't he said
if you really wanted to meet him you'd
go and meet him and i thought you know
something you're right i got on the
phone and i got an appointment with earl
nigel now that wasn't an easy thing to
do earl was the most listened to men in
the history of the broadcasting industry
at the time earl nightingale lloyd
conant started the night galconi
corporation who literally started the
personal development business as we know
it today in recorded fashion he was
considered the dean of personal
motivation there was probably a couple
of million people that would have loved
to sat down with him but i got the
appointment at the end of the meeting i
had a wonderful time there when i was
leaving i said earl
what is the big deal what is the real
secret of light to making things happen
well he said there isn't any secret to
success bob he said it's a simple matter
of figuring out what you absolutely love
to do
and then make a decision to dedicate
your life to it then every day you're
going to be doing what you love to do so
the problem with most people is they
never decide what they love to do and
they don't make a decision to dedicate
their life to anything they just go from
one thing to the next people have
regrets i mean if you want to go to
nursing home and just feel that for a
half for a minute if you're looking
through their eyes you can see there's
regret well most people do but most
people don't do anything
you see i often say how do you do
something
well there's where the goals come in
that's where the purpose for life comes
in
you're going to have a main purpose you
got to have a purpose for life and
you've got to have meaningful goals
they've got to be meaningful you're
trading your life for it
like i often say in a seminar
i want you to imagine you're at the end
of the road
and you know you're at the end of the
road
your body's so weak
they've got you tied in a wheelchair
or they've got you in a crib bed
so you don't follow
kill yourself right
just imagine all you can do is relive
your life
i want you to imagine
you're there
and you go back and think i wonder if we
had a move there what would have
happened if we hadn't started that
company remember we're going to
sell the house and start that company if
we hadn't done this i wonder what would
have happened
and then cut if i could only do it over
again
i said wouldn't that be terrible
spend the last days of your life like
that wouldn't it be better
if you look back and say wow what a trip
gotta remember we did that remember we
blew our brains out on that we lost
everything we had
but you know when you lose it big enough
it can be accelerating and then we did
this and what you're doing is laying
there and you're reliving your whole
life
and that's the goal got to have the goal
i've always asked how do you stay so
young
and i tell them i don't hang around to
all people and i said that i think sort
of as a joke one time
but then i realized it was no joke it's
the truth
i
i don't mix with anybody my age
i'm 85 years old in july
and
so i was born in 1934
that's a long time ago
and
i don't go by age of anything
i've become aware that age is
it's a number
and it has nothing to do with who we are
what we're going to do when we clearly
understand that our life will change you
know the idea of 65 for retirement is
pretty well accepted worldwide
and it was accepted by otto von bismarck
when he was chancellor at germany
somebody said you know we should have an
age where people can stop working the
government just send them a check he
said that's a hell of a good idea so he
just arbitrarily picked 65.
well a number of years later when they
were going to do it in america they said
is anybody doing that they said i think
they're doing it in germany what age 65
and it's accepted
65 is age of retirement
why would we want to retire at all
see ivc retire as pulled back from life
that's what it means why would we want
to do that i never want to do it i never
want to retire i think that would be a
despicable thing to do when people go
into forced retirement in nothing flat
they're dead
you see
when i'm made for work work is made for
us
and when we clearly understand that
um i think things start to change for us
i um i think people should ask
themselves how old would they be if they
forgot their age if i forgot my age i
think i'd be around 48
maybe not even 50. 47 48 maybe 46
i like the late 40s i think they're good
years i think that's how old i'd be
and i lived like that's where i am
the idea of slowing down or
that's just so foreign to my way of
thinking
i i don't i don't think that way
and the idea of retirement it'll never
happen to me
um
i'm going to go full tilt
right until the show's over
that's my attitude towards it i don't
hang around all people most old people
are old people and they talk about old
things you know in their room and this
thing all the time we ought to believe
that we're creative beings and there's
nowhere we haven't gone that we can't go
so let's get up and get moving that's my
attitude and age when
president john kennedy
asked
the father of the space program the
famous dr warner von braun
what it would take to build a rocket
that would carry a person in the moon
and bring him back safely to earth he
answered him in five words
the will to do it
the will to do it
pretty
light simple answer for such an enormous
question
but i'm going to tell you something the
will to do it
that had a lot of power in it
what do we mean by that the will to do
it well will is one of your higher
faculties your perception
reason memory imagination intuition and
the will
will is a mental faculty that gives you
the ability to hold one idea on the
screen of the mind to the exclusion of
all outside distractions
you know it would be you'd be
hard-pressed to figure out how many
things are trying to grab your attention
at any given time but there's all kinds
of things going on around that are
begging your conscious attention
you can block them all out and keep one
idea on the screen of the mind with your
will
will is a mental faculty that gives you
the ability to hold one idea on the
screen of the mind to the exclusion of
all outside distractions it's the will
that gives you the ability to
concentrate
concentration is a powerful mental tool
how do you develop your will i'll tell
you
you take your pen
or a little black marker
and go opposite to your favorite chair
there's a wall opposite your favorite
chair put a little dot on the wall do it
when nobody sees you doing it and nobody
will ever notice the dots there
every time you sit in that favorite
chair
focus on that dot bring all of your
conscious attention to bear on the dot
now when you look at your mind will
wander that's okay don't feel bad
because it wonder bring it back to the
dot every time it wanders if you if you
concentrate on the on that dot for um
a half a second you'll probably set a
family record our mind is so busy you
focus on the dot you find your mind
wander don't feel bad bring it back to
the dot you can get to the point where
you can concentrate for quite a while
and i'm telling you you concentrate for
a while you're developing great powers
or get a candle in a candle holder
and put it somewhere around your
favorite chair
when you're alone light the candle and
stare at the flame and stare at that
flame
until you mentally become one with the
flame now again your mind's gonna wander
don't feel bad about it bring it back to
the flame
just bring it back to the flame
when you learn to concentrate on one
thing
you can concentrate on anything because
that is how you develop your will
opportunity is an interesting word and
like most words
it's misunderstood see the average
person is looking at opportunity as
something they're going to get
so they're out looking to get something
opportunity is what you're going to give
see it's the person that's thinking of
an idea how can i do more how can i
provide more service for the people we
provide service for do you know i spend
almost all of my time thinking of how i
can help you more than i'm helping you
i'm here in my studio we spent
a million dollars building a studio so
that i can communicate more effectively
with our clients
opportunity
is in giving it's not receiving it's not
getting it's giving it's sharing it's
putting something out there success is a
funny word
nightingale had a great definition for
it he said a person's successful if they
know where they are
and they know where they're going and
they're progressively moving in that
direction he said that success was the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal anyone that has a goal and they're
moving towards it they're successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't i wouldn't say
mother teresa
has a lot of money okay but she's a
pretty successful lady attracting what
you actually want i think james allen
put it very well in his little book as a
man thinketh he said you don't attract
what you want you attract what you are
now think about that
if you want to attract what you want
you've got to see yourself already with
it you've got to understand that you've
already got it first of all clearly
understand this nothing is created or
destroyed that means everything's
already here if not in one state
certainly in another
where did the iphone come from the
iphone came from a series of ideas that
individuals entertained in their mind
and they kept holding the idea until the
stuff came to them that enabled them to
build the phone the stuff had already
been here
nothing is created or destroyed all
science all theology teach that if
nothing's created or destroyed
everything that is already here
our problem is we've got to wait until
we see it outside before we believe
we've got it start dealing with the
non-physical world with the invisible
world with the world that you can't see
through these little peepers that you've
got here we call eyes
start to see yourself mentally you've
been given the faculties to do that use
your imagination see yourself already in
possession of the good you desire
that will flip your mind onto a specific
frequency and you do think on
frequencies it's on that frequency that
good you desire is going to start coming
towards you and you will start moving
toward it
if you want to attract what you actually
want you've got to see yourself now
already with it and no it's only a
period of time until you moving toward
it and it moving toward you and you
become one with it stop and think of any
large company
i don't care anyone right
you can go
to the leaders of that company
and you can say who are your stars
i mean the ones that are really making
it happen and they've all got a few
say
what are they doing that's so different
why don't you find out what they're
doing and teach it to everybody they all
well everybody couldn't do it
why are they doing it you know something
the stars don't know why they're stars
and they'll say well they're smart
some of them aren't very smart
smart's got nothing to do with it
they have shifted their paradigm
they've knocked the wall down
and they built an image and they
followed the rules they just didn't know
what they were doing i didn't know what
i was doing i was there and over a
million dollars a year i had no idea
what the hell i was doing
i'd say i was cleaning offices that was
almost incidental
what i was doing i was reading this
every day i was listening to the
recordings every day i was reprogramming
my subconscious mind what keeps people
stuck month after month year after year
90 some percent of the population are
stuck
you've got people graduating with all
kinds of degrees and the results
wouldn't indicate that they know very
much at all
most people don't understand what's
going on inside there's something that's
stopping them it's called a paradigm
see when paradigms are in control
nothing changes nothing and that's why
most people they get the same results
year after year
people know how to do better than
they're doing the problem is they don't
know why they're not doing what they
know how to do
see it's the paradigm that produces the
results and if we're going to change the
result there's only one way to do it
just one you're going to change the
paradigm
a man's environment is a merciless
mirror of him as a human being
and if he thinks his environment could
stand a little improvement all he has to
do is improve and his environment will
improve to reflect the changing man
all knowledge all power is a hundred
percent evenly present in all places at
the same time your spiritual dna is
perfect so is mine there's perfection
within what we've got to learn is draw
it up now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you watch a video and just get
motivated the science says you have a 35
chance of actually following through on
your goals that's not good enough no not
for you believe nation we got to do
something but when you write it down and
you create a specific plan of action for
the next week that number jumps to 91
chance of you following through and when
you commit to somebody else like leaving
a comment on this video it jumps to 95
you need to follow through on your goals
so what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you
everybody wants to be happy but not
everybody is happy
you know i could take you back to the
man that gave me this book ray stanford
i was a very unhappy individual i was a
sad soul believe me
and i remember one day he said
proctor
you're going to have to change
he said would you like to be happy
well i used to think that was something
that
happened to some people but
you weren't in control of it
i really never knew
that i could control my own happiness i
did not know that and i'm going to tell
you something
there's a whole lot of people who do not
know that
otherwise you wouldn't find so many
people who are pretty sad
he says i'm going to tell you a secret
proctor
and he said if you get it
you can benefit from this until you're a
very old man
he said you are in control
of your own happiness
now he said i'm going to tell you why
you're not happy
there's a power or a thought energy
flowing into your consciousness and you
know what you do you bottle it all up
inside all of your energy's focused on
you you are the only thing you think
about
poor me i wish i had some money i wished
i wished i wish to wish
but your thoughts are always about
yourself
if you find someone else to help
if you can help someone and i'm going to
tell you there's a whole lot of people
out there want help
if you will focus on helping other
people
you're going to be one happy cat
now
i don't think i got it right away
but he knew probably i wasn't going to
get it right away
and so every time i saw him he said
you've been helping
well
i wasn't helping anybody i was trying to
figure out how to get some money how to
help me
i want you to think about this for a
moment there's so many people need help
chapter 14 in the science of getting
rich
is a powerful concept leave everyone
with the impression of increase
if you do that you're helping people
happiness
is always found
in the person who is focusing on helping
other people if you want some amazing
john assaraf motivation check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there setting goals is an
intellectual and imagined exercise that
your conscious brain right i'm going to
show you one of the little brains today
from the city here on my desk your